thanks everybody I'm really happy to be
there
um so today I'm going to talk about a
modern type Python and
let's see what we're going to see today
so I will first start to introduce the
history of python and type and we will
see that this kind of a weird story and
then we will
dive into this uh typed python ecosystem
that my title is talking about and at
the end we're going to look at a library
named Dockery which is the type using
this type ecosystem applied to machine
learning and spoiler alert I'm one of
the maintainer of this Dockery Library
let's jump directly into
the main topic and is python is Python A
type programming language
maybe in the audience can you raise your
hand if you think it's true or a false
statement
okay there is one one thing one one
person who's in style programming
language well it is a type programming
language in the sense that you have type
in Python like you can check the type of
an object but precisely it's a
a duct type programming language
uh let me explain what the typing mean
so this on the left you have an example
of a python function is doing uh adding
to to object and the right it's the same
function uh written in rest which is a
stack static type programming language
like uh or Java
um and on the and and what things which
is quite of obvious
between those two is
um in the dog typing language in the
duct typing so python you do well you
just have your variable and you do your
operation whereas in a static typing you
have to add some stuff here and this is
the type of the variable you're saying
that here you write this function and
you expect that X and Y are U PSI so
it's like numbers and you say the return
numbers and in Python you don't have to
do such a thing it's like so this is a
difference between doctyping and tactic
typing and the idea is in duct typing
you can pass kind of any object to a
function and whereas in static typing
you have like a well a fixed static
signatures that you have to respect
otherwise the program is not going to
work
um
let me explain a little bit more what is
exactly duct typing the idea a bit bit
behind the typing and why is it called
deck is like it's this philosophy behind
this python is if it works like a duck
and talks like a duck then it's acidic
it basically means that in Python an
object doesn't really care if inside the
function it's from the type that it's
supposed to be you just want it to
behave like the the object it's
expecting so it basically means that you
can pass all objects to python as long
as
they follow some
uh some characteristics then it will
work in the in the program and it's
really an opposite from a static type
language where we actually need to pass
the correct object otherwise it will
just not accept the function even though
maybe you don't you only use a subset of
the feature of this object it will still
complain
uh
this is kind of the idea of the typing
is this this is how python behave
basically it's like uh like okay you all
can understand this this this photo but
we try to plug an electricity and an
electric cable into a a pig's hole and
uh it looks weird but technically it
will work in the sense that you will be
able to plug it and that's how python is
working is like he don't care if it's
actually uh
so it's actually an electric uh plug he
just cares that it has two holes and
then it will see when you try to plug if
same stick fail something doesn't work
it will just you know explode kind of uh
whereas if you were in separate so in
rest here it will basically say no you
cannot plug this even though it python
well you can't plug it you will just see
what happens when it's happened
um duct typing is one of the reasons of
python success
um it has it's really a lot of uh Pro
argument for attack typing it's simple
and fast right so basically you don't
have to put any types information in
your variable it means that you have
less character to type and if you you
can write code which is almost look like
server code which is super elegant let's
say you don't need to think too much
about abstraction you don't need each
time such create a function and you want
it to work on several objects to create
an abstract class which is going to
encapsulate all of the abstract
behaviors so that gesture function can
be written you can just pass several
different objects to the same function
and and you will see what's going to
happen and again not two variables it's
really an important part of the typing
but it has some cons as well it's kind
of hard to maintain because
well if you don't exactly know what
going to your functions then each time
you do a modification you don't know
like maybe you use this function with an
object and you add a new functionality
inside inside your code it's not going
to work with
um another Factor we could because you
expect the behavior which is not
available on this object and you don't
have a way to know what's supposed to go
into this function what's supposed to go
into which kind of object it is so it's
sometimes hard to maintain and one of
the other problem is error will be catch
at runtime rather than complete time it
means that let's come back to this
example that let's say you know this
will not work when you're going to plug
these things or expect electricity to
come and it will not work with put it in
your in a big hole in a big noise sorry
and uh this in which python you will
catch it at runtime it basically means
that your program will be running and
you will try to do these things and it
will it will fail whether that with a
static type language
like you will see before and at compile
time or like like it will just not be
valid code in terms of of writing it and
you will have an error way before this
happen and you know you will basically
be able to catch those kind of small
mistakes that you can do
um
so if python is a duct type language so
it basically means you don't have to
precise a type inside your function why
is this modern python in 2023 full of
type and type hint type information now
let's take a look this is a code example
from a fast API which is a really known
web framework and I mean you can see
I hope you can see where is my most for
example so this is like from the readme
of fast API and you can see here you
have some string information float
information you create a function you
say Union of a string and none and this
this looks like a static type language
like you have some information in the
signature of the function and it's kind
of weird because I was just saying that
python is this dark type language it's
one of the main things that make it
popular is that you don't have to do
this kind of thing so let's try to
understand what happened and how come
this is like a kind of
in in 2020 this is a normal way to write
python code than using the type in let's
see how it happened
um
one before going into explaining how it
happened let me just explain you what is
the advantage of having Thai paint in
Python and this will explain how it
became it came into the language it's
kind of expressive to be able to it's
really expressive to be able to say what
you're functioning expecting and like
you have a signature it means that it's
like you have a contract with the people
who are going to use the library or your
function is like I'm expecting this and
this will work if you give me these
objects uh it's kind of it's easy to
onboard new people on your code base
when it's full of typing because well
they don't they know they look at the
function and they can reason easily they
know what's going to go into the
function one of the most important at
least according to me uh functionality
of typing is like IDE like Pi charm or
vs code or veeam it's a really love
typing for them it allows them to do a
lot of shortcut for you it's like they
can they can do um
if inside the functions they know what
kind of object is expected they can show
you the the method of this object that
is available and if they don't know it
they have no way to to to to suggest you
some some method right and and that's
why ID really love
um
typing it makes refactoring easier
because you can catch some small errors
that you will do and you will be able to
find bugs without running the code and
uh just statically analyze that's the
contract between your different function
is correct
um let's take a look at the history how
all of this happened so python released
in 1991 and 1991 by uh this guy famous
uh python author uh 10 years later he's
not alone anymore he's he has a team he
really spiked on 2.0 uh at this at this
time python is fully duct type you don't
have any things related to uh type hint
in the language
2006 python 3.0 happened to be in
development and at this time the start
to think about all of these typing
things that we see today in the language
um one thing that they realize is like
at the beginning so I say python in 2006
without type no way to say that your
function expecting to work on int or in
this abstract class and they realize
that people actually sometimes need this
information for example this was like in
Python you can you have this dog string
and people were putting a lot of
information in the dark string so this
was like let's like this was some code
that you can see in in the in this time
like people were type information in the
comments of the variable in the dark
string of the variable and they were
using this dog string for this and
basically what it showed is people
wanted to have a way to express type
information into the into their function
even though it was a it's a dog typing
language
uh then uh 2006 the first pep python
incense enhancement proposal so it's
basically a feature that people want to
add on python
um and and this is like the function
annotation which is different from
typing but basically we move from the
things that you see on the left and it
will go to the right it means that
instead of putting those information
into the doc string it's now a valid
python uh python it's valid python to
put this information after the variable
uh in this way import the router
statement in this way and
um
so what's happening what's going to do
here is like you you
um this will be saved into the function
into this annotation which is this
dictionary which do the mapping between
X and whatever you have here and it's
just a dictionary function annotation
this is not something that it's still
python at this time is still fully
doctyping and it will always be you can
you don't have to do this but it's just
an optional thing that if you want to
add information to your function
um and functional notation there are no
no more than a way of associating
arbitrary python expression with various
parts of a function at compile time it's
just a way to do Association of your
functioning signature and whatever you
want this means that this is actually
valid python here you can put a sentence
after your X you can actually put any
object not even a string uh yeah like
this is this this is still valid by them
and so you see here we are not still
helping talking about type about typing
it's just a hint and information that
you can add to uh next to your to the
variable and of course this pep was sync
to be used for type hinting but at this
time they were really going in in a safe
way and just introduce little by little
this feature just like this is
annotation this is not yet typing
because python is known to be a dog
typing language
um
well that's basically what I said but
there was officially so at this time
officially no type hinting in Python uh
to be continued so let's wait so we had
to wait eight years later to in 2014 and
actually type in the reintroducing
python uh like so what we know know
about python all of this Union optional
things that is introduced in this 484 in
2014. Let's uh and just for it for the
history actually all of the things that
has been introduced in this uh in this
pep in 2014 I've been proposed 10 years
before by the creator of python so all
of this thing optional Union all of
these things it has been already coined
10 years later and just to show you how
long it took to actually go into the
language because again python is known
to be duct typing and people didn't want
to do all of this typing singing python
the Creator already already had the idea
but he it takes a lot of time to
actually make it something part of the
language and let's take a look for the
people who don't know what how it looks
like so you have now this typing uh
Library which is in the standard Library
which have a lot like type information
any optional and this year and you have
a so this is still losing the type
annotation
um yes there's a annotations that we saw
earlier but now with actual type
information that's really represent type
um we have a lot of advanced type
feature like type work overloading
covariance control variance forward
reference a lot of complex things that
allow you to express a lot of
information about the type in a function
and since 2014 we have seen 16 pep in
six years going into the into the python
project that are related to type in and
uh and in in in it's basically each year
you have more and more and more type in
related feature in the python so let's
sum up uh let's sum up so python is not
the sagically type programming language
it is a duck type one and type it slowly
enter the python world as I said it took
almost 10 years before the creator of
python calling all of these typing
things and then before it go into the
language but python is adding type in
related feature at an exponential rate
like if you see the python 3.12 you will
see five or six pep related to type in
um okay so let's take a look and during
this time of all of this uh like as a
typing I've introduced in Python code in
Python code base and become kind of a
norm to to use there are a lot of tools
that have been built around this type
pint ecosystem uh let me present several
of them probably the most important one
is my pie my pie is a static type
checker for Python and it basically
checks that your type it makes sense it
means that if you have a function which
a it expect hint uh hint like one or
zero or two and in a later in your code
you'll pass a string then it will say uh
be careful you probably are doing
something wrong or otherwise you need to
change it as a signature of your
function to express that your function
is always able to work on string 10
years old project it actually starts
before the first typing typing peps in
Python and they were using their custom
type syntax
um yes second one big type is a kind of
different it's a runtime check so it
basically means that um
though this one is uh going to catch
kind of error at such a time it's mean
you don't have to run your code to catch
the error this one will be catch at
runtime it means that
um your function your program will stop
you will stop stop to work if you pass a
a wrong type and in some time when you
want to do some critical uh programming
and you act you really want it to behave
like you it's supposed to behave you
want to catch those small things you
want to cut you want to stop early you
want to stop you want to have an early
when those kind of thing happens
validation using python type hints it's
five year old it's quite popular
nowadays and it's kind of at least for
me it's kind of a revolution in a way
people use Python it's actually has been
introduced before the data class feature
and it's kind of basically what inspired
the data class features that now we have
in the python let's just briefly take a
look at how it how we do uh how we write
code with pythonic basically in pythonic
you create this class
and you have the attribute name and
history it's typing
and it's kind of um a strict like a
stroke that you can see it's here or in
rest it's like you basically say that
this object has this property uh this
attribute and this is the the the type
that it's supposed to to work with and
pylanche will do a lot of things for you
so that it will always make sure that
you have those the those those that
those type are respected and um we'll do
a lot of validation it's basically it's
like when you're passing some data you
can be sure that either it's going to
fail at some point or that you are going
to have the correct type into your
object
um first API first API is a modern fast
web framework for building API and it's
there is based on a standard python type
hint and it's based on pythics that we
just saw before it's five years old and
it's super popular
let's see how it looks like to build an
API with fast API so basically in fast
API you say I create
a model it's like basically a a pedantic
object and you say that you have you
create a function which is expecting
this model and that's all that's all you
need to build I mean one light decorator
here but here but it's a really
important part is you write just a
python function and pasta API if you use
a type hint with pythmic fast API will
come and we'll be able to kind of
understand this function and say okay so
if it's expect sorry this object that he
knows that he can he have to an endpoint
is going to if it is an object of this
format is going to come it's going to
parse it into this python object and
give it to the function and it's really
fast to write that's what you call fast
API to write apis that way because you
you don't have to think about the
passing about a lot of things and do a
lot of automating thing for you for
example building documentation building
uh open API specification from you
because it here we'll read it from the
python code and can build it on the Fly
let's like really fast API is really
impressive in how it has been
democratized into the python wall so
this is like the number of stars I know
stars are back proxy for a popularity of
a project but uh I don't have a better
way to do it so but you can see that
flask is another popular web framework
probably the most popular one and you
can see that in in couple of years fast
API has been as popular as flask even
though at the end of the day they are
doing the same thing
SQL model is kind of the same ID but
this time to manage a SQL database is
created by the same guy I'm going fast
here because I don't have a lot of time
left a typer is the same way to create
CLI based on same as in typing so
basically create a function and instead
of practicing manually each parameter
and then calling a function it's just
like take your function you expect the
name and then addresses then the CLI it
will expose this exact same parameter we
just have to write your python function
um what about machine learning framework
actually there is one Library which is
not that well known it's called drug
typing and it's but it's allowed to use
type information and shape information
inside your array based code so if
you're doing some deep learning or any
numpy based uh coding some sometimes
it's actually quite useful to express
the shape of your function so basically
you say I make I want to create a
function which is doing matrix
multiplication and well we all know that
we there is this constraint that the
shape the last dimension of the first
Matrix should match the first of the
second Matrix otherwise you cannot do
the matrix multiplication and with this
Library we can express those kind of
information
um but it's kind of the only one in the
machine learning world so let's let's
sum up so a python type ecosystem is
growing and it's growing fast as I as I
show you first apis really take over the
python web development World in I don't
know a couple of years it's really
impressive
um and yeah type based libraries are
overthrowing long-standing libraries
um but the machine learning Google
system is still missing those uh typing
Base Library and then here we are enter
a Dockery Docker ISO again this is a I'm
one I'm one of the maintainer of this
project that's why I'm talking about
here today and basically the idea is
like we're doing this type in ecosystem
to the machine learning World
um
yeah so we basically look at what
happened with the web development
ecosystem so pythonic fast API SQL
models are kind of a new wave of those
tools for uh building application and
this is only based on type hint like
this is a successes Bain on this feature
and it's great software as well but the
main thing that makes them different
from the other are those type pins
um but tomorrow well app will change
drastically because AI enters the battle
uh I mean actually all I've heard of GPT
stable diffusion with like all of this
AI uh AI models that basically can only
can work on modalities that are Beyond
text like stable diffusion for example
it's creating an image out of text
um of Whispers that can uh
take your voice and put it into text and
you see here that those applications
work on a modalities not only text
um one month ago gpd4 has been
introduced it's like this llm but it's
always he's able to understand image not
only text so like this is kind of the
next step in the applications that we're
going to build is not only text based it
will be a video image all of these
things will be part of the of the
application
um
and if you look at pedantic pedantic has
some predefined types which are really
useful to build applications for example
you have that time URL you even have a
payment card number object into pied
antique just to show you how with all of
this it's focused really on
today's web app but not on tomorrow
weather because tomorrow will warm up is
it's not based on on on on text ensuring
only you will need to be able to handle
image audio video 3D object this is how
the new application will will be needed
library for representing sending and
storing multimodal data with a focus on
machine learning and neural search it's
built on top of pyrantic it's we like to
call it as a python tick for ML or a
hint of python chick for machine
learning it's fully compatible with fast
API and it's one almost one years old
now
um and we just did a big release one day
ago when we introduce a lot of python
chick and type in related feature
um we just move we just moved to the
Linux Foundation AI data and we are on
six six people working on this project
so this is basically what uh Tucker is
doing we work on the different
modalities in a seamless way let's say
and we provide some storage and
computability
ah let's it's like I I call in this
pedantic with a hint of ml let's
actually take a look at how it looked
like so this really look like first we
will so here we want to walk with a with
podcast data and podcast is uh composed
of an audio well the most important part
of the podcast but not only uh let's say
you want to build a search engine for
podcast uh audio is not the only
important part in the podcast it's
actually maybe the least relevant when
you want to search for for podcast uh
for example thumbnails it's like the the
image on the podcast is really important
uh the title as well and the description
is super important if you want to build
a central line with this
um and here with with Dockery you in the
same way you will do with identity you
will create this document which is like
a model
um
and we can express a lot of things
related to to machine learning like the
the shape of the tensors that you expect
in your podcast and then you can create
a dog vac which is basically a vector of
all of this podcast which is uh suitable
to work with machine learning and yeah
that's kind of the feature that you can
do with with with python always
the difference with pyrantic is that
it's a referred so you can create you
think in the array mode it's like you
have a vector or list of object hazards
are just one single object
um another part of Dockery is like it's
a
or overheim for Vector database yeah you
have
uh it were connected to several Vector
database let me jump this is my last
slide
so basically what we try to do is uh
Dockery is to be the python chick
formation for machine learning uh we
have another tool called Gina which is
kind of a fast API but
all of this machine learning things and
the SQL model to work with SQL data we
have something as well in Dockery when
you work with Vector database which are
like the database as the AI world and I
will stop with this thank you for
listening to me
thank you thank you Sami I think that's
very thorough interesting song and we
also have a very Lively q a sessions so
just a quick question some quick
question for you first what is your
position on runtime type check using
type guard or their type versus
statistic type analysis when to use what
I think it looks like they're doing the
same it's actually kind of completely
different I think
static type analysis you should actually
use it if you have typing in your code
base it's like a good things to do
runtime checking is different it's
really depending on what you want to do
because sometimes you don't sometimes
maybe your code will still work even
though you don't pass the right type and
if it's working it's working it's
depending on the if your application is
quick it's really critical or not and if
you really want to be really sure that
you do like let's say you are
implementing a payment system you want
to be sure that what you have as input
is what you expected so that nobody
tried to hack You by doing some hockey
passing another object or a long type
and it's going to I don't know remove
all of the money on your broken card or
something like this
awesome nice questions any thoughts on
the future of python and role of type
hinting will duct typing be dropped in
Python 4.
I don't think python 4.0 will ever be a
thing but I'm pretty sure that we can
say that python will always be duct type
language I mean it's what make python
python it's why it becomes so popular so
I think for me those two things type
hint and duct typing work together
sometimes for example for me when I'm
doing some Jupiter notebook code I don't
use typing at all I mean I just want to
write fast and to prototype and when I
want to build some serious and uh
foreign
library then I will use type hint even
though I will be slower at the beginning
I know that it will be better for me in
the future
awesome next questions any current Pips
on type hintings that you are excited
about in the future release
good question
um
his name
yeah I think I'll introduces annotate
objects in the typing Library when you
can basically go beyond just having the
type in but you can precise additional
information and I think first API is
planning on adding a lot of interesting
feature around this and it's definitely
one of the things I'm most excited with
okay let's we'll see in the future next
also have another questions about how do
you see the features of typing in numpy
I think I think
um maybe it will not be directly numpy
but this Jack typing that I saw that I
show I think it's basically able to
express shape information and and array
related information in the typing at
least for me it's very sexy I mean I I
like doing it it's kind of a new way to
write program even to read a code it's
it's easier when you can actually
understand the shape and and in numpy
based code you usually you see a lot of
comments like this array is actually of
shape XYZ and it's basically what we see
earlier with the people who are putting
information in the dark string and they
wanted something in the language to do
it and I think this will come to maybe
not numpy directly but in the ecosystem
awesome thanks uh I think that's all the
questions we have time for today against
your conclude everyone's please give a
warm balls to our podcast